MALE SPEAKER: We have
some very special guests
to chat to us about Alan
Turing and Bletchley Park.
So first of all,
Sir John Scarlett.
Sir John was chief of the
British Secret Intelligence
Service from 2004 to
2009, and today he
is the chairman of the
Bletchley Park Trust.
Sir John.
And Sir John Dermot Turing, who
is the nephew of Alan Turing.
He first of all studied
genetics at Oxford
and then turned to the law as
a partner at Clifford Chance.
And he's a trustee
at Bletchley Park.
Sir John Dermot Turing.
SIR JOHN DERMOT
TURING: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: And
first of all, we're
going to be joined by Hangout
by two of the guys involved
in making "The Imitation Game."
I'm a little bit worried
because I can't see the Hangout.
Oh, there's Graham, and
Teddy is there as well.
You can see them, but I can't.
Graham is the script
writer and executive
producer of "The
Imitation Game."
And the script of the film
topped the 2012 Black List,
which is Hollywood's list of
the best unproduced screenplays.
And it got the highest score in
the history of the Black List.
I'm delighted to see
that the script has now
made its way into the film.
And also on the Hangout
in the smaller thumbnail
there, Teddy Schwarzman, who
is the founder and principal
of Black Bear Pictures, and he
oversees all the operations,
the development, the production,
and the planning of the films.
So we're going to talk
to them in a second,
but first of all we're
going to kick off
with a clip from the film.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-That's what you're doing here.
The top secret
program at Bletchley,
you're trying to break
the German Enigma machine.
-What makes you think that?
-It's the greatest
encryption device in history,
and the Germans use it for
all major communications.
If the Allies broke
Enigma, well, this
would turn into a
very short war indeed.
Of course that's what
you're working on.
But you also haven't
got anywhere with it.
If you had, you
wouldn't be hiring
cryptographers
out of university.
You need me a lot
more than I need you.
I like solving
problems, commander.
And Enigma is the most
difficult problem in the world.
-No, Enigma isn't difficult.
It's impossible.
And the Americans, the Russians,
the French, the Germans,
everyone thinks
Enigma is unbreakable.
-Good.
Let me try, and we'll
know for sure, won't we?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: Right, so
over to Graham first,
who wrote the script.
And I understand, Graham, that
you've been very interested
in the subject of Alan
Turing from a young age.
How did the film come about?
GRAHAM MOORE: I always imagined
that I'd end up like you guys
actually working in
computer science.
But I didn't.
I ended up being a writer.
And so I think among techy
computer-minded kids,
Turing has long
stood as inspiration,
someone who thought
differently from everyone
around him and because
of his differences
was able to see the
world in a new way
and do things that other people
didn't think were possible.
So it was sort of
a dream of mine,
even after I became a writer.
Turing was a subject I
always wanted to write about.
And yeah, I feel so
privileged that Teddy and I
got involved in doing it.
MALE SPEAKER: How long did it
take from screenplay to screen?
GRAHAM MOORE: I just
remember [INAUDIBLE]
about four years
ago now actually.
Alan Turing was one of the great
geniuses of the 20th century,
and I'm not.
So you're sort of like, oh
my god, this is a huge story.
This is an important story.
It [INAUDIBLE].
You hope you can add to it.
You hope you can add
to Turing's legacy
as a need to be
[INAUDIBLE] preserved.
So yeah, after about a
year, we found our way
to Teddy and to Morten
and developed the script
for another year.
And then we were
off into production.
MALE SPEAKER: And
over to you, Teddy.
I mean, at first
glance, it doesn't
look like the most
promising material
for a blockbuster film.
Did you find it easy to get
the film off the ground?
TEDDY SCHWARZMAN:
You know, really
what we were trying to do was
tell a story that we thought
was of great importance
and try and protect
the essence of Alan
Turing and his legacy
while not shying away from
the pain and injustice that
naturally comes with
telling the story.
Sort of getting
it off the ground
was really more about reading
the script and then saying,
OK, how are these pieces
going to come together?
And I think we believed that
the importance of the story
would generate it interest
from directors and from cast.
I think the interest on
the casting side and people
like Benedict Cumberbatch
and Keira Knightley
and Mark Strong
and Charles Dance.
That was something we were
so incredibly lucky to have.
MALE SPEAKER: Great
that the story
has traveled so far
internationally.
So Graham, had you visited
Bletchley Park before you
got interested in
making the film?
GRAHAM MOORE: I hadn't
visited Bletchley
before making the film, but at
various stages in the writing
process, at the mid stage, I
went and visited Bletchley.
And it's amazing to
walk around there.
You can even go in and
touch the machines.
And I think that's
something as a writer,
that tactile experience of
seeing it in front of you,
touching the walls,
it reminds you
of the responsibility
when you're
telling a story like this.
This is a true story.
This is about real people.
This really happened.
And so we all felt-- and I know
Teddy and Morten and Benedict,
Keira, everyone felt this
tremendous responsibility
to be able to tell this
story accurately and fairly
and do it justice.
MALE SPEAKER: How
much of the film
was actually shot
at Bletchley Park?
TEDDY SCHWARZMAN: I think
it was about four days out
of just a little over 40.
We had looked at it to
try to figure out could we
shoot Hut 8, which you'll
see in the film there.
But for a variety of
reasons, it made sense
to actually build a hut just
so we could have flexibility
from a shoot standpoint.
So we ended up finding
sort of our hero
at Bletchley Park in Nettlebed,
which is just off of Henley.
And we did the exterior
huts up around Bicester.
And then we did some
of the interiors
that we could at Bletchley.
MALE SPEAKER: Fantastic.
And finally Graham, as
we'll see in the film,
the Alan Turing
character is actually
very funny and amusing.
What did you draw on to show
those little glimpses of humor
from the true story
of Alan Turing?
GRAHAM MOORE: Yeah, I think
having some humor in the film
was really important
to all of us, me
and Morten very much included.
Because I think that
Turing's life was funny.
I think that one of the things
that I was so fascinated
by in this film
was giving a really
three-dimensional
portrait of Turing.
Because he was a willful man.
He was a driven man.
He was a passionate man.
And we wanted the
film to express
all of that, the sort
of awkward situations
that he could experience.
Obviously, his is a story
that ends so tragically,
and we wanted the
film to show that.
We wanted the film to face
full on the tragedy of what
he experienced, but also
certainly the beginning
to depict the full
spectrum of Turing's life.
MALE SPEAKER: Brilliant.
OK, well thanks very
much indeed, gentlemen.
All best wishes for the film.
It's in cinemas from
November the 14.
Thank you very much for
joining us and all the best.
[APPLAUSE]
Right, so now we're going
to see another clip,
and then we're going to turn
to the gentleman from Bletchley
Park.
This next clip is
called Christopher
and is about the beginnings
of the digital computer.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Are you trying to build
your universal machine?
I read your paper at university.
-Is it already being taught?
-No, no, no, I was precocious.
So, you theorized a machine
that could solve any problem.
It didn't just do one thing.
It did everything.
It wasn't just programmable.
It was reprogrammable.
Is that your idea
behind Christopher?
-Human brains can compute
large sums very quickly.
Even you can do that.
But I want Christopher to be
smarter, to make a calculation
and then to determine what to
do next like a person does.
Think of it, electrical
brain, a digital computer.
-Digital computer.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
we'll start there.
So, Sir John Scarlett, you've
been chairman of the Bletchley
Park Trust and obviously
before that involved
with the Intelligence Service.
How important was
what Alan Turing
was doing there for the war
effort and subsequently?
SIR JOHN SCARLETT: What was
done at Bletchley, which
was actually
technically part of MI6,
the secret intelligence
service at that time,
although in practice
and in reality
it is the antecedent to GCHQ,
what was achieved there is--
well, it probably is the single
biggest continuous achievement
in intelligence terms ever.
It's hard to underestimate
the significance of what
is achieved.
And we need to
remember that history
when you watch the
personal story in the film.
MALE SPEAKER: Sir
John Scarlett gave us
the sort of importance
in military terms.
Tell us about the
importance in computing
in scientific terms of what
went on at Bletchley Park.
SIR JOHN DERMOT TURING: Yeah,
this is quite interesting.
There's this rather
charming scene
between Keira and
Benedict that you
see where they talk
about this sort of idea
of a universal computer.
So you might get the sense
that this machine that's
built in the movie that's
called Christopher-- and I
won't explain why because I
don't want to spoil it for you.
But this machine
called Christopher
is like the world's first
electronic computer.
There's a lot of
Anglo-American tension
about who actually made the
world's first stored program
electronic computer.
And for stored
program computers,
there's lots of first electronic
computers and so forth.
So there's many, many
claims around this.
MALE SPEAKER: And now we do have
a very special guest with us
today.
Ann is related to a Googler,
I believe, and worked
on the bombe machine at
Bletchley Park in the war.
Can you tell us
what you did there?
ANN: When I worked on the
bombe at Bletchley Park,
is there anybody else here
who worked at Bletchley Park
at that time?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
MALE SPEAKER: Just you.
ANN: I'm obviously the
oldest person here then.
Well, I think it will
be a marvelous film.
I've read about the man
who is playing the part,
and it seems to me he
will do a very good job.
But we lived outside
Bletchley, and we
came in by bus every day.
And we worked three
eight-hour shifts,
three times with eight hours.
And there were about 20 of us.
And it was very exciting.
The bombe brought up
the right setting.
And we sent off and
then occasionally Hut 6
would tell us what we'd done.
Not very often, but
just occasionally
we were told what had happened.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you so much for coming,
and many thanks
for what you did.
[APPLAUSE]
And just finally over to Dermot
to ask, much debate about why
the bombe was called the bombe.
Can you explain?
SIR JOHN DERMOT
TURING: Well, I can't
claim to have the
definitive story,
but I've asked lots of people.
And the idea is that the
bombe was named the bombe
because the Poles, who had
done this amazing work trying
to crack the Enigma in Poland
before the German invasion
of Poland in 1939,
they'd invented a machine
to try and uncover the settings.
It wasn't as sophisticated
as the Turing-Welchman bomb
that you'll see in the movie.
But apparently they called
it the bomba, and so then,
well, all right.
You've just restated
the question.
You haven't answered it.
Why did the Poles
call it the bomba?
Well, we think-- and I'm willing
to accept other theories,
by the way, so if anybody's
got better ideas than this,
then please do let me know.
But we think it's because,
well, first of all it
made this sort of
ticking noise, and when
it got to the end of its runs
it make a clonking noise.
So it tick, tick, tick, clonk,
sounds like a bomb, doesn't it?
But apparently
also the Poles used
to go out and have a sort
of mid-afternoon snack
where they go around
to the local cafe,
and they just order an ice
cream, which is like a bombe,
like the French dessert.
It's a bomba in Polish.
So they did that.
But I think the
real reason is this,
that if you've got something
that's really, really
good, if you're
German you say prima
or if you're French
you say super.
Sir John and I have this theory
that if you're British you say,
"I say that's not
bad, not bad at all."
And if you're Polish you
don't say any of those things.
You say bomba.
So we think that
may be the reason.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
Thank you to all
our guests, really
fantastic and interesting stuff.
Thank you so much
to Ann for coming.
Now, the film begins
in 10 minutes' time,
so we're going to take
a very quick break.
Go and get yourself an
ice cream or a beer.
And we'll reconvene just
before 6 o'clock please.
Thank you very much indeed.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Who are you?
-Alan Turing.
-This war, we're not winning it.
Break the code,
you have a chance.
-Enigma is the greatest
encryption device in history.
-It is unbreakable.
-Based on the
incredible true story.
-What if only a machine
can defeat another machine?
-You do not have
to do this alone.
-You've got more secrets
than the best of them.
-It's a superb
thriller, five stars.
-My machine will work.
-The world is an infinitely
better place because of you.
-"The Imitation Game"
in cinemas November 14.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]